[Music]
hello you're listening to a special
quarantine edition of life is short i'm
your host justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
with me as always in in and out of
quarantine it's my brother christian not
always
i shouldn't say that why do i keep
saying that that just sounds like it's
got like a radio my my siamese twin
christian long
yeah um but lately we've been around
each other a lot and uh
and we've been staying positive and and
thank you for um allowing us to do these
quarantine check-ins because we've
really been enjoying them they've been
such a nice fun for us to do so
thanks for listening to them yeah so um
and always thanks to dr dave and all our
friends that we're checking in on i
think this week we're going to first
check in on dr dave and see how he is
handling things dave is on the front
lines in new york city
he is at columbia med and so here we go
let's do it
dr dave kessler
dr dk dr k
obviously he's very busy
hello great i'm going to try to greet
you with a different just a different
positive
affirmation every time i call
hurrah
save it
uh
how are you doing
okay
how are you guys doing uh we're fine
we're good we're um we just had a you
know
because this thing keeps changing and we
keep learning new information as you've
been saying uh
we just had a few questions about what's
happened this past week and
are there are there new things that
you're seeing are there changes either
positive or negative that you've been
noticing
um well this was a a difficult week in
new york
um
for sure yeah some personal losses and
and i think probably a lot of people
don't have to go too many degrees within
their lives
to have seen that as well yeah um yeah
i'm sorry dave
you know in terms of what what i i've
seen i guess from the national news
um a couple of small changes but maybe
they give hope the trials that fauci was
was speaking about yeah for some
antivirals i i would say they had very
modest effects but it was nice to see a
array of sunshine on you know some
potential impact on
days of disease again i think the focus
on the cure
is um
probably not going to be as
as impactful as the focus on prevention
right we were just talking about that
because even if they do find something
that seems to be working
isn't it with all the trials and the
testing isn't isn't that going to take
at least a year yeah well some of these
trials there are you know um
compassionate use and emergency use and
i think it's just really important we've
been through this before and even back
with um h1n1 you know and other and
multiple other examples um when there's
so much attention on it sometimes
there's there's these really hopeful
things but but this is why you have to
do larger trials and
conduct scientific studies because
even things that have been long-standing
like uh held true certainly into
hypertension meds yeah um over time were
found to not actually be effective when
you got more and more data so
i really think it's too soon i mean i
don't mind the hope that she always keep
hoping yeah sure i'm not expecting huge
things for you does that the particular
drugs mentioned this week and does that
apply to hydroxychloroquine
is there maybe some hope that
yeah and bleach i want to talk about
injecting bleach because we're on the
face oh my god
just to be clear everyone he's kidding
yeah kidding
[Laughter]
you know i think that it just says
something to our our nature as as human
beings like we want so badly to um to
find a cure to find a fix
it's surprising to people sometimes to
learn that um
there are often for most diseases there
isn't really a simple sort of uh
silver bullet or one size fits all and i
don't expect this to be much different i
think the thing that will have the
biggest impact from a scientific
perspective is once we get to the point
of a vaccine
um and and that is that is sort of um
you know probably at least you know next
january the soonest or so before we see
that going on a mass scale assuming
everything goes you know successfully i
read a really interesting article in the
atlantic where they they compared it in
a sense to y2k in in the sense that um
there was so much preparation that that
was done to prevent white a crisis like
y2k and and then when it
you can look at y2k in two different
ways you can say oh well people were
exaggerate it was an exaggeration or
it was um it was an averted crisis due
to preparedness and uh
and and i i wonder if
if if you would agree with that that
that this is similar in the sense that
you know
let's say the numbers are kept
i mean there's still p obviously you're
seeing the worst of it you're seeing
people dying now but let's say they're
kept relatively low relative to what the
the uh projections were
d is it safe to say that this wasn't an
exaggeration then it was just
you know whatever measures were put in
place have worked and are working i only
read part of that atlantic article but
um
you know to
in one on the one hand
um
i i feel like what's so different from
y2k is that
um
there was monumental uh
failures to be prepared um
here in some other countries we have had
um
just a staggering amount of worldwide
deaths
staggering amount um so i think that to
your point like would it have been much
worse especially here had we not uh done
things like stayed at home
[Music]
at certain states yeah it definitely
would have been a lot worse um can we
learn from it and say hey next time we
should have done a lot of these things a
lot sooner i really hope we do and not
only that um you know we're already
talking about planning for
you know second wave or sort of what to
do when other when flu season hits in
the fall
and i'm concerned justin that we're not
preparing enough for those times we're
already sort of past the new cycle of
the surge and people are now sort of
looking to find fault and and you know
everything and
we need to stop blaming each other
including the president we just need to
start working together and saying let's
cut through the bs like what do we need
what do we need for the fall um what do
you think what is it well i mean what if
you if you could offer a prescription
right now for what that is
what could you tell people
well you know if i had a if i had a
magic wand
because i don't know how realistic this
is i would say let's really take a hard
look at health care and how we
fund it in this country um i'll just say
that like a lot of hospitals are
looking at their books and saying we are
either going to close
or we need to figure out how to start
making enough money to stay open um the
carers acting and some recovery money
has helped certain places other places
we're seeing around the country are
closing there are emergency rooms
closing now more than ever you'd think
we'd learn the lesson like stop looking
at emergency rooms as places that that
need a business model um they're like
roads we need to maintain them we need
to keep them open and you know what many
parts of healthcare are similar so sure
there's parts of it that are
you know the business model within
medicine cannot be the only model there
needs to be a public health model uh
where we all realize that what we're
paying for yeah is times like this in
the extreme but it doesn't need to be a
pandemic for us to need uh those
emergency services to be a well-oiled
machine right that is only solely
focused on public health and not on how
to how to keep their doors open from a
financial right because even outside a
pandemic people wait till the last the
la the last possible minute to go in and
get help and you had mentioned this last
week that a lot of these things are um
were preventable i mean could have been
prevented had they come in have they had
they sought help earlier but of course
people don't want to do that because
of insurance problems and um
and yeah i i just want i i think you're
right i'm sure you're right that a lot
of this could be solved with a national
health care plan that that yeah yeah and
you know it's not even like let's let's
like let's even use into it sure like my
magic wand would love just national
health care where it's not about um
anyone's profit margin that decides
health care policy a hundred percent but
but like let's even like find the middle
ground in between let's just agree that
um just like we want um you know we want
to have a fire uh
department right
like like even though maybe maybe um
locally you know people might be sitting
around six days out of seven and then
the seventh day they're there for the
fire we want police you know we want
these are all sort of like social
programs
and community workers right we're an
emergency room do we want access to care
and um and we're paying for it one way
or another so let's at least build it
right i think a perfect example like
just to
like right now i'm thinking about um and
maybe there's not enough time between
now and fall but you know heck you know
we built entire icus and football
stadiums around the city um so i think
that we could look at our actual ers our
actual infrastructure some of which in
the city hospitals but not just the city
hospitals but like in our crumbling and
and you know you need paint jobs but
let's just look at like you know where
we're seating patients so that they're
not coughing on each other so that
they're not coughing on the doctors we
are not safe right now
god and and and instead of being
um
incentivized to say okay everyone let's
look at your ers first and say fix them
so that we're safe for the fall let's
really fix that you know from an imp
from a building
yeah um yeah like no we have to focus
now and i get it like i don't blame you
know my hospital leadership or anything
like that or anyone really everyone's
playing with rules they're given and i
don't blame them for saying shoot we
have to open up the operating rooms so
we could start generating not just
general review treating actual patients
but that's what generates revenue so
that's where the focus on
capital will probably go not towards uh
getting us ready for the next infectious
outbreak in the fall god i i hope this
does
spur people to action and create
just you know larger change i i just
hope it creates like
institutional change which it sounds
like it needs um
thanks dave i i'm sorry that you you had
i can't imagine what you're going
through and i i know you alluded to i'm
sure a lot of your colleagues are
struggling and and i know there's been
um
you know i we've all everyone heard
about the suicide of of the doctor in
new york um and i can't imagine the
pressure that you're all under so uh i'm
so sorry and and you know we continue to
be so grateful
thanks for bringing that up i mean i
feel like that's the families um i want
to respect the families obviously
it's their story to tell and actually
they've been really
um they've been they've been telling
that story really well so i think people
can
yeah look to hear their their sort of
points about that um and i'll just say
that um
you know one thing is destigmatizing uh
mental health in general and um you know
mental health is is intrinsically part
of our physical health we all
struggle with various aspects of it it
shouldn't be seen as sort of black or
white there are
national suicide hotlines and stuff like
that people should be aware of but also
don't be afraid just to reach out um to
a friend who maybe you haven't talked to
in a while just check in on them be
there for each other show kindness
show love to each other and reach out to
each other because you never know who's
struggling and doesn't have an outlet
someone to share those things with
especially now especially with a lot of
people
inside and dealing with pressures that
were unforeseen and they may not be
equipped to deal with because this is
such a new situation for everyone i just
want to say the national suicide
prevention lifeline if you
are struggling with anything like that
it's
1-800-273-talk that's
8255-1-800-273-8255
gratitude and and uh so sorry that
you're all struggling right now um in a
way that we can't imagine but we're very
grateful for
so thanks man i think we're all really
in this together and um
sorry it's a a dark note right now no
week
but but i think that the other end of it
is that we
have always persevered we've always you
know hope
is what keeps us going forward yeah and
um i just i don't like the tone of
what's been happening now that you know
again sort of like the this happened
after 9 11 where it was like rah-rah you
know and right and now we're getting
clear
and it's like now we can start to look
go back into the store of our teams and
start to look for faults in each other
yeah i just you know i just urge people
to sort of think twice before you know
engaging in those kind of things on
social media and um just think how can i
help you know what can i do even if it's
just calling a neighbor yeah let's do
something positive yeah be kind that
always seems to uh
be be the yeah the the way we should all
live i mean even outside a pandemic
but this is shining a particular light
on it
uh but yeah yeah
and well thanks dave that's really
valuable and and uh i appreciate it and
it's it's okay i mean it's it's do it
doesn't have this doesn't have to be
like uh
you know you don't have to be a
cheerleader this doesn't have to be a
buoyant
part of yeah no i'm sorry it's a downer
no but no it's sobering and it's it's uh
it's helpful to be sobering i think
sometimes especially can i tell you
something one of the nice things about
telehealth has been
um and one of the nice things about
people being kind now is that i've found
um people are are seeing their doctors
and their health care workers as people
and um
and and that's been released but like
you know when i'm seeing people and i'm
seeing them in their homes and i'm
seeing them as people and i think a lot
of people you know are experiencing zoom
work calls and saying oh look you know
like we all have we all deal with you
know
maybe a kid in the background or a pet
in the background or you know just see
where we're living and you know we're
seeing each other as more human that's
something i hope we don't lose yeah
we're seeing each other as all basically
the same uh it's
as as close as we can get to seeing each
other on the toilet
you know it's it's like the old saying
some cases that's happened as well i
think it's confucius for socrates who
said well everyone sheds
i forget who said it um thanks dave uh
really appreciate it buddy we'll check
in next week
all right okay all right send you
sending you love
all right all right take care everyone
bye
you know we brought up uh humanizing the
effect that it's had this this situation
in in terms of humanizing doctors and
seeing doctors and seeing everyone as as
people i mean god it's
in in a much more superficial and
important way you see celebrities famous
people as you know they're in their
homes and they're trying to
eat madonna's doing stuff and they're
what cooking and stuff but um
in a far more important way it's
humanizing doctors and i was just
thinking about our own doctor uh
hemingway we had a wonderful
pediatrician yeah he was just the
ch
he still is just the loveliest warmest
person and so great with kids had such a
gentle spirit you know but um when i was
a kid
i i was i dreaded seeing him he he
represented because i was so afraid of
the doctor and
and what happened in the doctor's office
but in retrospect he could not have been
a more like benevolent soft sport just
like the calmness and and despite that i
was still like i feared him you know
scary i still remember the smell of that
you don't both have to remember the
smell of isopropyl alcohol and related
to fear of going to the doctor um
it was the alcohol right the contract
and and that and the uh what was the tab
i hated that the strep throat the tongue
depressed
oh i hated that feeling
that feeling lasted that feeling when
yeah it lasted like half a second but it
was the worst half a second of your year
and this is how dr hemingway would do it
he'd be like okay
jay open your mouth it's gonna be a
little uncomfortable he was just so like
calm is that yeah that's not a very good
it's a little too muppety yeah i was
doing ken coopers who directed he's just
nothing into you can can talk they
remind me of each other can kind of talk
like that but you're right and dr dave
is right i think when he talked about
how people are connecting more because
of
zoom call you know people are working 50
of the workforce is working from home
now and and
i think for the most part they're all
using zoom and things like that so
there's some there's i think there's an
interesting irony in that in that
we are
um
connecting more as people because we're
like he said we're being led into each
other's private lives more
while we're disconnected you know we're
connecting more through this screen and
through this technology so
it's an interesting irony we're not
seeing each other now but yet we're
connecting more
um sorry to interrupt uh
you didn't hear a word i just said well
no i did i did we're connecting more
even though it's through a screen and
that that's what happened to me last
night i had i had that feeling i was on
a zoom hangout with uh some friends and
some of whom were people i i
normally i don't see that often i'll see
like
you know maybe twice a year or so maybe
once a year um
and it was so fun and it made me even
with dax dax is going to be on the show
in a couple weeks and we we uh
we did an interview the other day and he
made the point that
were it not for this we we we would not
make a plan to hang out people are being
more deliberate too about right
scheduling that because it's uh
that too yeah yeah that too sorry no
that that's in it that's a good point as
well thank you don't stick to it it's a
little different
a little different than what i was well
in my defense sorry hi
sorry you got a duolingo alert no no no
but
that's been going great thanks for
bringing that up um no i got from dave
texting me and he said um
i just want to dr dave dr dave yeah
sorry dr dk
uh dr kessler said the family set up dr
breen's family set up a fundraising site
in her honor so i just want to read that
um
it is you can go to www do you have to
say that anymore no i know oh my gosh
www.http
don't you
colon
backslash backslash you know i was proud
of myself because the whole thing he set
the whole link and i was proud of myself
for not reading the http part we
shouldn't be laughing um this is uh
this is if you want to donate in dr
breen's honor it is
dr d-r-l-o-r-n-a
breen
b-r-e-e-n dot com
dr lorna breen and um did he know her
yeah sounds like he did and he said he
said i'm grieving hard this week [ __ ]
he said she was one of uh
leadership and she said he said she was
a real vibrant person well um
that is really [ __ ] sad it's the
it it messes their brain right that's
why i mean what that's or the
combination of that and the stress i
don't know
who knows i don't want to speculate but
i can't i can't i i would guess i mean
it's
and that's again something that i had
not considered until this happened uh
the the stress that the mental stress
that it must the toll that must be
taking on some some of these health care
workers and
you know you think about soldiers what
they go through um
the pt i was just reading oh yeah it's
well speaking of soldiers that i that
more people have died from this
than died in vietnam the entire war yeah
which is that's an insane statistic
especially if you've seen the ken burns
uh docuseries i i was reading an article
about the um
it was in response to the tiger king and
how we're really not focused on the
right the the real message of the tiger
king you know where people are focused
on how
eccentric the characters involved in it
are but at its heart is this story of
this real tragic story of like what
we're doing to big cats and how a lot of
people are trying to um
promote the big cat safety act not now
uh in congress because it's still up for
i think it's still up for legislation uh
the big cat safety act and so that's
i've read an article about that and they
talked about in an event that happened
really tragic thing that happened i
think in 2011 i'm not quite sure where
where somebody one of these
quote-unquote sanctuaries or you know
roadside zoos released all of these
animals and i remember do you remember
this there were like
30 lions and jaguars and they were just
like roaming through they were roaming
neighborhoods yes and
and the cops are like animal control
whoever maybe some swat team had to come
and
they had to kill it it was in the
documentary it was or was it i think so
i don't know if that specific case but a
a case like that well this article was
in an element that i hadn't considered
was the
the mental the uh mental toll that it
must have taken the psychological effect
that it had on these poor
cops or whoever law enforcement who had
to come and
murder these beautiful animals uh anyway
um let's well sorry sorry but it's but
as dave said i mean like you can't
escape that it's you can't you check in
with a doctor who's on the front lines
of this thing and you know yeah it's
it's hard to i know you you keep saying
it's i can't put myself in your shoes
but it's
true i think it bears repeating you say
it a lot but it's true i think unless
you
um have experienced what it's like being
in dr dave's position or the position of
being in a war or something like
there's nothing in your life that you've
done
or in my life that i've done that i can
really compare it to you know no
an overnight boy scout trip in cold
weather isn't really a comparable
situation i know i know seeing
like a turtle dying on the side of a
road as
you know i i remember when our family
hit we hit a deer on on the taconic i
remember that remember that and it was
oh it was um you know traumatizing you
know what's crazy i was very young i was
maybe seven or eight or something but i
remember so clearly that i was listening
to my walkman
at the time and i was listening to a
tape i was listening to um wouldn't it
be nice by the beach boys oh i remember
hearing that
how ironic i know weird
yeah i remember those what it's amazing
i i just imagine some of our younger
listeners maybe having no idea what
we're talking about our tween audience
yeah we do have a really we have a
vibrant vibrant audience yeah we have
some tweet shorties
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and would
shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
christmas tis the season to deck the
halls and exchange presents with loved
ones but over the past decade a new
tradition has emerged binge watching low
budget made for tv holiday movies the
all-new podcast series business wars
christmas movie wars looks at how
christmas films started creating massive
profits and how the battle to have the
highest rated christmas movies has
become an intense christmas tradition in
2009 the hallmark channel aired
wall-to-wall holiday programming from
thanksgiving to christmas surprisingly
it was a ratings bonanza and rocketed
the little watch channel to number one
hallmark's competitor lifetime took note
and launched their own block of
christmas movies this sparked a rivalry
that has lasted almost a decade and then
netflix started making christmas movies
and what started as a business
competition turned into an all-out
battle for viewers attention listen to
business wars christmas movie wars on
amazon music apple podcast or you can
listen early and add free by joining
wondering plus in the wondery app
[Music]
okay well let's uh
let's switch let's talk about something
fun yeah um we got some good um emails
this week from
you guys yes
some questions some fun would you rather
yes i'm so excited i haven't read these
yet i haven't read all of them but i
let's just grab a couple of them okay
she said so these ideas came from my
four-year-old son and three-year-old
daughter oh yes i bet they're gonna be
good i also have a 22 month old son wow
she's been busy where are his ideas we
we live in vermont and the quarantined
life has been rough on them i'm a mental
health counselor and therefore my
schedule hasn't changed oh weird so my
husband is home with them uh so she says
how her four-year-old and how her
three-year-old responded to these
questions
would you rather have to wear a princess
costume every day or a frog costume
that's so good
do you want me to tell you what the
four-year-old said and the
three-year-old before your answer yeah
wait wait is the son a four-year-old and
the daughter another four-year-old son
three-year-old daughter okay
well i'm oh you know this isn't a kid
who was raised in the 80s with very
specific gender norms and paradigms uh
i'm guessing the daughter said did the
daughter say princess costume yes okay
and the sunset fry sorry um
i all day you have to wear the princess
i would rather i imagine i would let's
say for a year it doesn't specify um
mine is pretty easy
yeah yeah well and and not to mention
you with a mustache and a princess
happen all day
and not just because of the gender norms
thing
although that has to play a part it
would be much more i i it's for me it's
more
um it seems much more difficult to have
to dress up as a princess there there's
more to the costume not necessarily it
might be more encumbering to be a frog
you know to have to wear the frog outfit
maybe more encumbering but i think
easier to put on and take off because
the princess there there's so many parts
to the pieces there's the dress and the
tutu
the crown and the little one
and a bra perhaps
why do you need a bra you don't need one
but i didn't need a bra do you know what
a bra is for
i'm just what princess are you picturing
like a really like jasmine yeah like uh
like a shoe like a fun lover oh you have
to share your midriff
oh
even even like the most conservative
princess would be annoying to dress up
as a a conservative princess would be
more annoying to dress up as right the
more pieces yeah
but uh less embarrassing a hipper
princess would be easier but more
embarrassing so all right frog easy for
me yeah and for you too right because
you love frogs
yeah but it's still gonna be really
embarrassing imagine either way we're
like worse a headpiece a frog headpiece
you could hide easier
with a princess everyone sees that it's
you it's easy for me all right number
two but by the way really good one good
is that allison um it's yeah nelson's
kids or her kids yeah yeah i think this
is their ideas all right number two
be stuck in the car
when 22 month old has a poopy diaper
or
eat broccoli at every meal oh that's
easy for me i love broccoli well it
depends how long you're stuck in the car
does it mean stuck in a poopy car
forever for every meal you have for a
year you have to eat a meal in a poopy
car or eat broccoli with every meal then
it's very easy for me then it's
definitely broccoli
yeah unless unless you just get used to
the poopy car smell so if you have like
two weeks into the thing you're like ah
that's just what it's like to eat food i
mean you get used to it yeah you would
this i've heard that about people who
live near paper factories have you ever
passed by they stink isn't that weird
that paper should smell the process of
making paper shouldn't smell so bad but
um here this is also a good point for uh
future questions that people want to
write in and i hope they do because
these are really fun um it helps to be
as specific as possible about the
parameters of these would you rather it
does and this is a good point this is
yeah okay so the four-year-old says
stuck in a car with poopy diaper oh
really the three-year-old says um
four-year-old must hate broccoli same as
above poopy diaper they must hate
broccoli yeah or just be used they've
been living with that poopy diaper
somehow maybe for 20. then allison says
um broccoli what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you kids she said what the [ __ ] well wtf
yeah okay wtf is wrong with you kids you
know it's funny people are gonna start
speaking that way uh they're gonna
spread those those online abbreviations
are gonna start they already have
slipped into
our vernacular you know wtf
you're jk hey
lol to that uh yeah a broccoli easy i
wonder why kids hate broccoli so much i
never really understood that idk
brussels sprouts i understand kw cause
brussels sprouts are kind of farty
but broccoli is so benign to me
it's a strange thing all that kids all
hate broccoli i'll tell you what though
broccoli has a real farty smell but
before you it doesn't taste farty
obviously but it has a farty smell when
you're making it i guess so yeah have
you ever got a package of broccoli raw
broccoli what's wrong with raw broccoli
raw brock that's hard to say raw
broccoli um
i love it i don't know all right the
third one so you would pick yeah that is
weird you pick broccoli brussels sprouts
also have a farty smell um i would
definitely pick broccoli i like broccoli
and sometimes i broccoli i could have
broccoli also here's the other thing
it's so benign a 22 month old poopy
diaper is pretty bad it's different than
like a two month two month old poopy
diaper
for a second it sounded like you said a
diaper that had been poopy for 22 months
but that's when you know once kids are
eating real food yeah then it gets
really stinky yeah it's from my limited
experience with changing diapers
more dr spock but uh isn't that a good
reference
you don't mean the star trek character
no you mean the guy who wrote the
the book about raising kids um
did you congratulate your own reference
just to make it clear that it wasn't the
star trek maybe maybe subconsciously
yeah a younger diaper doesn't smell that
bad ah
a more juvenile diaper it like smells
like nothing an infant's diaper is
god you know i'll i'll never forget
that when i [ __ ] my pants in
kindergarten it must have smelled so we
talked about that on the show no let's
save it i'll save that okay that'll be a
treat for listeners in the future if
you're just tuning in a new listener you
were what sophomore or junior
i was a freshman uh okay and finally
number three would you rather sleep i
know your answer for this this is easy
number three sleep with rotten cheese in
your bed
or
wear garbage shoes
garbage shoes yeah what are garbage i
don't know but i know your answer i love
these kids these kids are hilarious
um
don't you wish you could just like hang
out i mean i guess we do that with our
nephews so the four-year-old says
garbage shoes and the three-year-old
just started to cry
[Laughter]
oh i didn't know that was an option i i
would just start crying
if i knew that was an option uh it's
easy for me definitely garbage shoes
yeah definitely
whatever those are i mean i even the
worst type of garbage shoe i can imagine
i think i'd rather i couldn't sleep i
wouldn't be able to get to sleep
forget rotten cheese i think i would
rather wear garbage shoes than like even
good sleep with like string cheese in
the bed next to me oh my god you know
what's crazy i it's not crazy why do i
keep saying that this is crazy and i'll
say it's very millennial of you it is
it is everything is is uh
is uh i'm making everything more lit
than it should be what's the word uh
hyperbola
yeah i um we have in this in this in the
house we're quarantining in um a little
like uh you make it sound like we're
squatting in someone's house
this is your house
i don't know why i said it that way
um in my house i have a uh aloe aylo is
it aloe or aloe i think it's aloe
aloe potato is it potato potato maybe
aloe aloe elastic
you have
hey i have jayla yellow jayla you're
thinking of
[Laughter]
uh i have a jlo garden i have an aloe
garden um and i was so and i
was clearing brush a couple days ago i
was like
whatever i was trying to clear out this
bush i was cutting down this bush and
and i knew that it had poison ivy on it
and i was trying to do it before it it
bloomed because right it's beautiful out
it's everything's starting to bloom in
spring so i did it last week and um i i
got a few little like nicks and like
cuts from from the brush and i thought
that was it like whatever it's going to
heal over the last week it has gotten
it's transformed into this christian's
looking at it right now into this itchy
pretty disgusting that's gross but it
really itches and um i got so excited
because i was like oh i have this aloe
garden or halo i'll say now and i can
spread some on there
it's
it still smells it smelled so bad um it
smelled like kind of ch cheesy ew i know
yeah yeah didn't i want are you sure
it's aloe it is uh no but it might be
rotten it might be like rotten ella's
stomach just sorry sorry that that we
could use that in a would you rather
would you rather be slathered with
rotten aloe my stomach is like flipping
around
or sleep in a bed with what does the
kids think it's like rotten cheese right
well it's been a pretty crazy week in
quarantine i see
you slathered rotten aloe on your poison
ivy yeah well i can't believe we did a
lot of yoga we have been doing a lot of
yoga yet shout out to tim cenessi he's
great to follow on youtube
uh sorry so just to finish your little
email here yeah oh that's not well uh i
would wear garbage shoes i mean yeah
unless the garbage was made of rotten
cheese did they mean so even then i
would rather have it on my feet than in
my bed although it would float up to you
especially on a hot day mention doing
things
what a gross one yeah but good one well
done yeah uh she said then she said are
you sure you want children
that's funny i want children more more
now
because i it's so [ __ ] kids are the best
we were just facetiming with our nephews
uh and he's had the funniest is he at
the best age he's like he's around he's
two
oh yeah almost three no two no
yeah i don't think he's quite two and a
half sorry i don't know yeah maybe two
and a half yeah okay whatever two days
anyway thank you for the laughs and
break from reality during this time stay
safe ally thank you ali that was a great
yeah great one great letter um so yes
we've done yoga yeah every day this week
you know we should we were going to try
our uh we've done what else what have we
done oh we watched the
dance the jewelry is so good and and uh
my mustache continues to grow
that's right in fact you've been getting
shamed a lot for the mustache we talked
about this already how you look like
bob's burgers but uh our uncle actually
shamed you
publicly
i posted a picture of my new luke by the
way not to bury the the lead but we
should preface this by saying just when
you're considering this our uncle's name
is dick long
that's right i'm just going to leave
that out there i'm not going to you know
editorialize it richard long but he
as far as i know he exclusively goes by
dick
long so
in the phone book yeah you can imagine
what that might look like he was in the
military also at one point and so when
they were calling roll call you can also
imagine what that would sound like last
name first first name left right long
comma dick right that's just his name
yeah we're not being crude no so i
posted a picture of my new new luke on
on social do you like when people say
that i know on my socials and my feed
that's not as gross to me as socials
yeah uh and
the response was of my mustache how was
it received it was either like people
either said oh it looks good or that's
funny looking because it's true it is
funny looking yeah um i think it's silly
because people with mustaches it's it's
not a look that people have anymore it
used to be such a popular look yeah it
was at one point in the 70s was like a
really sexy look yeah it was like a
macho
man look and now it's like a pervert
look and i don't know when that happened
well i don't think it's the pervert the
pederast took over the mustache yeah
well it's like what happened to charlie
chaplin's mustache that's true you know
hitler's just chaplin was the biggest
star in the world
for years it'd be like trying to think
of a specific look that brad pitt let's
say has or or
you know if someone's i don't know what
look he would have but like if somebody
if some dictator some like murderous
like tyrannical like you know you know
it's a good example it looks like
breakfast uh justin bieber when he rose
to popularity when he had that like he'd
always flick his hair every kid started
having that hair yeah and it created
like ticks in kids that hair flipping
tick yeah hated that look oh yeah me too
um i prefer justin bieber's little wispy
mustache look you do oh yeah yeah
i like that he's like committing to that
and
i i like that he's committed to that
yeah he's a little tiger king husbandy
right now yes oh my god tiger king
husband goals
yeah um but what are what did uncle dick
say
about your mustache every single person
either
laughed at it or said it looked nice
good in some way yeah but people have
been they're friendly on socials usually
and uncle dick said
commented
uh but you gotta read it verbatim
something to the effect of oh you gotta
read a verb i don't wanna look it up
something it was very simple it was uh
i preferred
i preferred um you when you didn't have
a mustache i preferred how you looked
without a mustache i think that's what
it was i prefer how you looked about
almost
[Music]
and first of all it's strange that he's
the only person i know who said anything
critical of it
and
two and more importantly i think
it's so weird to me that he has an
opinion about
when i look my best yes isn't that weird
yeah it is
yeah it is i like my uncle dick but i i
see him so infrequently i see him once
every few years at most that he it's
strange that he's cultivated an opinion
of your love how he likes the way i look
yeah hit you're
the most uh the best aesthetic that you
that he has an opinion of your aesthetic
i i wonder what he thinks of my look
like if i were to you should post a
picture on facebook yeah and ask him
what he that he had already
that he valued it in any way in a way
it's flattering that that our uncle is
considering
your
how different you might he's judging me
he's judging you aesthetically um i
don't think i'll keep the mustache
because of that once this quarantine is
over not because of that but because the
perverts have like i said taken over
that look and
i don't really want to be out in public
with it that's true for that long
it looks silly i wonder how that
happened i wonder how the mustaches
became synonymous with i don't know i
don't know because i'm just thinking of
there'd be an interesting malcolm
gladwell case for the the tipping point
we had we mentioned last week uh you
mentioned um
how it went from
like tom selleck and bert reynolds and
like studs like masculinity
there's probably one pervert that tipped
it over i wonder who it was jeffrey
dahmer had a little mustang no not like
that not like that well
in the purpose and he was he i wouldn't
classify him as a pervert though
no he was one but i i i feel like [ __ ]
skulls no no i know obviously he's
perverted was perverted oh but but the
things he and he's more of a cannibal
exactly
there he has attributes that trump is
being perverted right like he he
murdered people right it's it's like you
can't say about hitler you wouldn't say
about hitler his favorite color was red
yeah or he was he'd have a great sense
of humor right it's like yeah yeah the
the their negative attributes completely
so a pervert i would say like um
you know jerry sandusky is more of a
purpose oh right he didn't have a more
of a pedophile no that's true
um
yeah well maybe we should go this is
pretty slow
uh what should we do
can we read another would you rather
sure and it's getting a little long
that's all right let's do one more yeah
these are fine because there's a bunch
we'll save more for next week
um
oh someone jenny b had an um had an idea
for those paper cranes she wrote oh yeah
the guy who's making origami yeah she
said here's an idea for the 1000 paper
cranes put each one up for an online bid
for a minimum of one dollar plus postage
the people receiving the cranes will
receive the wish of ending coven kobit
19 and then he can donate the proceeds
to the hospital
or covet research that's cool he'd help
make his own wish come true thank you
jenny b that's good
yeah so uh if you're listening sir yeah
i know jenny b
uh all right let's do
one more would you rather email okay uh
excuse me
hello hello this is from whitney h what
does that make you think of hello hello
hello oh yeah so that's what i was
thinking of this the song yeah for the
show yeah that we're on right now
okay this is from whitney h the subject
would you rather hello hello
uh myself and my boyfriend
play would you rather a lot normally a
few rounds before we go to sleep whoa
yeah it's our way of unwinding from the
day and have a giggle yeah i like that
there's nothing ever really off limits
in the game and they can get pretty
gross and pretty dark real fast so i
thought i would send you some of the
more light-hearted ones ah
uh you want some the dark yeah i want
the girls don't all right um number one
we should do these fast there's five oh
okay number one would you rather never
have to cut your finger or toenails
again
or
not ever have to maintain body hair face
pube face pubes pube pubes chest pubes
all the pubes all the pubes et cetera so
everything would stay the perfect length
forever
wait oh oh oh i see you never have to
maintain it and you just oh i'd much
rather uh do i wouldn't i wouldn't care
about that i don't care about having to
maintain hair
i i don't want my nails to grow can you
imagine living with i saw a woman in
this i think it's more about having to
do the work of maintaining the nails and
the hair because i wouldn't want to i
think that's what the question is oh
wait wait wait she's saying would you
rather not have to maintain your hair
or your nails exactly oh it's easier to
maintain your nails yeah but i wouldn't
want to pick the same hair look for the
rest of my life like now i mean you
sometimes you want a pervert exactly
yeah
exactly so i would rather um
have to keep maintaining my hair even
though it's easier to maintain your
nails yeah me too okay um number two
would you rather eat food in its food
form but it tastes like nothing
it would still have a texture feel and
smell
but had no taste
or have food or have food that is a
brown room
room temp mush that has all the taste of
food
oh i would rather taste the food yeah i
don't know the mushrooms you get used to
the i don't value texture all that much
would it taste like different foods or
yeah i think so yeah oh yeah i would
take the mush yeah flavorful mush for me
yeah okay um
all right number three would you rather
have tiny dicks for fingers
or or have tiny dick toes oh easy
toe dicks you put them in shoes yeah
yeah i might want to have toe decks yeah
it'd be kind of cool
uh wait why would you want to have toe
decks i don't know it might be
look funny it would definitely look
funny i would love to read up toe
selfishly
yeah and i don't wear a lot of like i
don't get go barefoot publicly that much
it'd be a fun thing to like
a fun party trick
this might be uh a reason to want finger
dicks
what if can you get sexual pleasure from
them right um
interesting consider that that would be
maybe pleasure overkill that might be
too much uh toe dicks then you'd have 11
dicks but think about this if you had
all your toe dicks in a shoe or a sock
or something it might be too pleasurable
maybe no you'd all be cramped in
that's true would you a 15 year old boy
sure friction would do it for you
all right four would you rather have no
lips or no eyelids oh no lips or no
there's no eye
your eyes dry your eyes
your eyes just bugged out when you go i
just wanted to
uh would your lips would it be like all
of this so all your teeth are showing
like this like shall we because she just
bared his teeth like that or would it
just be like the actual lip part like um
uh what was that jim carrey character oh
uh the the mask no no no a little like
the mask it's a version of the mask no
um
in liar liar no in living color when he
was oh yeah fire marshall bill yeah
let me show you something would it be
that if it's just the red part of your
lip i'd rather get rid of that
than the eyelids or
i'd rather get rid of my eyelids
really
be
really scary
because then you could wear
shades a lot you wear shades i already
covered masks yeah but not to function
in life
i would rather lose my lips
you would i lips are very important and
you could still talk yeah but imagine
like i hate to say i don't want to make
everything sexual but like imagine
kissing somebody with no lips haven't
you ever kissed somebody with like very
little lips
you mean when someone else has little
lips yeah i've never had little lips
don't burst your lips yeah uh
yeah it makes a difference but even
without lips you'd still have like a
ridge
where you're i don't know
i'm now picturing you and it would be so
gross it would just go from your
mustache hair right into your teeth
uh i would still say no lips i think it
just depends what you mean by lips i
think yeah how much of the lip and would
your eyes dry out exactly probably not i
mean i always assume these hypotheticals
are like you don't suffer right right
side effects okay and finally five would
you rather be too hot or too cold
it depends on how hot or cold but in
general it's like a manageable hot or
cold i prefer being cold oh really i
prefer being hot no wow do you hear that
stomach yeah somebody else was like can
justin eat something before you do these
oh you're you're you're reading a lot of
it
all right see those are the ones that
stick in my crawl i people write the
nicest
old man thing say it sure is i like that
expression i thought it was craw
oh i thought like crawl space
i think it's i thought i always thought
it was frog shorties stick in my craw
stick in my crew what's a craw i don't
know but i think it's craw is that like
our brother is going to shame us oh yeah
by the way speaking of our brother
damian uh he did shame us did we talk
about this how he shamed us for um
was that thing he said we mispronounced
iroquois oh yeah the native american
tribe uh
iroquois christian said iroquois i think
i said you're a kwai yeah and and he
said no it's actually you're a claw or
something right it was such a subtle
difference um yeah i gotta look this up
let me finish reading this little last
part now
um
thank you so much for the wonderful
podcast and helping me break up
which day is which i lost my job the
second day into lockdown so instead of
stressing and worrying i've chucked
myself into doing an online animation
uh course which i have been oh that's
meaning to get back into for such a long
time and focusing on my design portfolio
whitneyhughes.design and my little
online store things by pickles dot big
cartel this is a smart letter because it
makes me so it makes me so happy to have
um too much to keep me busy also i have
started re-listening to the podcast from
the beginning because it just makes me
smile inside and out cheers whitney the
podcast life is short on spotify and
wondering yeah or wherever you get a
podcast
thank you uh whitney yeah really nice
that was nice and um also yeah smart um
okay so our brother shane just dustly
text in a text he said it's cause
christian had said iroquois iroquois
indians david said iroquois he's gonna
love this you're a koi
not iroquois and then i looked it up and
i said it's actually irra quoi
iroquois
and he said i'm gonna need to see
sourcing on that
but we don't need to see sourcing when
he corrects us no
yeah okay all right
that's our brother but we love him and
he's funny and smart and if it weren't
for damian we wouldn't uh know dave
kessler and he's been such a great part
of the show
so
let's um
wrap it up
i don't know let's call her all right
might as well just for a minute yeah
we're going to call her mother really
quickly
we've been dealing with her a lot i've
been shopping for her because we don't
want her leaving the house and uh
justin bought organic avocados for her
and she got upset yeah genuine let's
hear her take it okay all right
uh and lemons she didn't like that i
bought okay she eats some oregano
yo yo um yo yo hey mom uh we were just
recounting the uh the fact that i bought
you organic lemons and i was telling
christian that you got sort of upset
that i got organic lemons and avocados
well because if something has a hard
skin um you don't need it to be because
you're not gonna eat the skin but it's
still porous yeah it's part of the gmos
and whatever
whatever toxins chemicals they're using
that gets into the whole fruit or
vegetable oh since when are you a
horticulturalist since when are you
since when are you where did you hear
that i mean i don't know i read you know
bananas and
avocados i'd like i'd like to see i'd
like some sourcing yes
well i have my sources you have your
sources all right all right that sounds
like fake news to me let's just call
please
just happy compromise
all right
agree to disagree hey what mom what are
you doing
well i just finished my yoga and then my
centering prayer and then i did mass at
the university oh
you know what today is today is
virtually
zoom the feast of the
oh what is uh do you feel centered
well uh
yeah mildly so
you're in the middle
in the midst of my anxiety
well
yeah what's number one what's number one
on the anxiety list
oh my kid's getting this and being
because i don't know if you really had
it justin no
no i know i may not have oh that's why
we're do you think i had it
yeah i think you did questions but if
this thing is so transmissible how would
he have had it and not how could i not
have gone in
i suppose but you know there's there's
so much now with the the immunity not
being um
something that is you know actual
well no it's just that they don't know
exactly what also but they say that 50
of people who have it don't show
symptoms so
i think it makes more sense
in light of that fact that justin did
have it because he had such mild
symptoms but at least he showed some
symptoms
well i'm grateful you guys
you lost her
lost her oh well anyway okay
i'm grateful you guys
uh well yeah she's been worrying a lot
uh but fortunately she's letting us shop
for her unfortunately she's
shaming you for buying organic produce
yes all right all right let's read a
letter yeah
by the way we're going to call her back
just in case you're thinking uh that's
mean that and we didn't hang up on her i
didn't want people to know that we only
hang up on jerry
yeah
who i don't know if he wanted a call
this week jerry's been hard to reach
we'll try them next week maybe yeah okay
this is from melissa a this is from
melissa a subject can we stay in
quarantine longer to keep getting extra
episodes are i don't think people are
going to like that but selfishly i like
that
um
hello justin and christian i just want
to let you know how much i'm loving your
quarantine check-ins that's great to
hear i love the podcast in general but
these extra check-ins are a great bonus
thank you melissa i work as a lab tech
for a company that runs animal blood
work so we are considered essential
personnel and are still working through
this pandemic i can listen to podcasts
at work so the extra episodes are really
nice right now your check-ins with jerry
are hilarious and i'm so happy your
grandmother's staying safe and healthy
my grandmother's in her 90s and
unfortunately was just uh confirmed
positive because of an outbreak in her
nursing home [ __ ]
thankfully so far she is asymptomatic
wow and is feeling okay that's wow in
your last quarantine check-in you talked
about nominating a business around us
that have been doing great during the
pandemic and i wanted to nominate a
small family-run pizza place cool
in my town this is a pizza place in
plainfield connecticut it is called gus
pub and pizzeria pizza rama i'm sorry
gus pub and pizzerama
it's a great name this is our favorite
uh in our town and we try to eat there
as often as we can the food is delicious
and the staff is always so nice and
helpful the owner is always helping
people in line and whenever i get a
pizza from there he makes sure to open
it for me to make sure i think it looks
okay it's such a nice restaurant and we
appreciate everything they have done to
keep serving food but also keeping
themselves and their customers safe
that's great
gus pub and pizza rama plainfield
connecticut anyways sorry this is so
long i really love all the happiness and
laughs that your podcast brings to
people thank you guys for everything you
do melissa thank you so much melissa and
um
i'm glad you did that because i was
wondering about you know other small
businesses we could talk about uh and i
had this thought i know it's not a small
business it's actually quite a large
business at trader joe's but um the
trader joe's near near us in westport
connecticut
there's also one in fairfield it's shut
down right now but the one in westport
the way they've been running things is
just so efficient and
there's a guy named their name their
name jared who is
i'm wearing a mask covering almost my
entire face and
i was there yesterday he goes hey justin
wow yeah really i mean i was like how
the hell did he you're so famous that
just my eyes
maybe from jeepers creepers i didn't
mean that i just i didn't mean that well
maybe subconsciously i did oh my god so
scary i got to examine that anyway um
thanks melissa and uh sounds like a
great place there and thanks to jared
and everyone at trader joe's uh for
keeping us all safe and feeling positive
and if you guys want to nominate a small
business that you like or that you own
uh feel free to do so um add life is
short at wandery.com we also uh love all
sorts of letters including would you
rather yes that's fun um and looking
forward to the last stance after you've
been watching episodes five and six uh i
love the stuff with isaiah thomas and
the detroit pistons that was so fun
maybe we'll talk about that next week
and we'll check in we'll try jerry again
next week and dr dave and as always
thanks again to dr dave and to all the
healthcare professionals and everyone uh
the delivery people the people at trader
joe's at the grocery stores everyone
keeping us uh sane and safe and um
relatively normal during this abnormal
time and thanks to all of you and to our
mother for picking up her phone yeah
that was nice we're gonna call her back
right now uh and yeah and to all of you
thanks for listening and we will see you
soon we will hear you hear from you soon
hopefully and you'll hear from us soon
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's produced by you christian long
and her
monica heading to los angeles and senior
producer is i'm pointing to brooklyn
michelle miesh lands audio engineer is
sergio enriquez
executive producers are marshall
louie edernan lopez for wondering
[Music]
you